[Music]
on this Saturday night state of
emergency
[Music]
dozens of powerful tornadoes carve a
path of death and destruction through
the U.S the heartbreaking and harrowing
stories of survival
budget backlash why are the feds forking
out for phones no one's using anxiety
and uncertainty one year on you should
be able to feed your child no matter
what the long-standing baby formula
shortage that still isn't resolved
banding together to celebrate drag
culture i as somebody who's been a long
time activist have been very impressed
the hot pink protection plan popping up
and standing up against hate
global national with Farah Nasser
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us We Begin tonight with a wave
of wild storms that are tearing through
the U.S at least 21 people are dead
after dozens of tornadoes swept through
parts of the Midwest and Southern States
according to the country's National
Weather Service there were at least 66
reported tornadoes across seven states
all within a span of 24 hours starting
Friday morning Fierce weather that's now
left behind devastating scenes in
ravaged communities in Arkansas
Reggie zucchini looks at that damage for
our top story tonight
the howling whale of a tornado siren
signaled to millions of Americans that
time was running out
in Little Rock Arkansas a monstrous
funnel swept across the city injuring at
least 40 and resulting in a level one
mass casualty event at the city's trauma
hospital it just brought the entire back
deck up to the front and everybody was
just panicking
just about two hours East in the town of
Wynn a deadly twister ravaged the local
high school and decimated what for many
took a lifetime to build I know and have
every confidence that we will be back on
our feet better and stronger than we
ever have in quick Fashion on Friday
Arkansas governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders
declared a state of emergency requesting
federal assistance from Washington they
have assured us that those resources
will be here and on the ground the White
House becoming accustomed to more
frequent calls for financial help
President Biden touring Rolling Fork
Mississippi on Friday a week after a F4
ravaged the area this community is going
to be rebuilt and rebuilt and built back
better than it was before this most
recent line of storms
contained just as raw a power as any
other as experienced by this driver
whose van was inside the Little Rock
tornado
this system was part of a rare dual
high-risk outbreak with nearly half a
dozen states impacted this is the first
time in I believe more than 10 years
that we've had two areas of high risk
farther north in Belvedere Illinois
severe weather is being blamed for a
roof collapse at a concert venue
video from the scene showing the Frantic
search for those under the rubble more
than 250 were believed to have been
inside one person was killed at least
five others taken to hospital the Powell
theater is is one of the Heritage places
around here and to see the damages just
heartbreaking heartbreak that could be
repeated with the us only now entering
Peak tornado season
now to the ongoing search of the Canada
U.S border in southern Quebec where the
bodies of eight people from an Indian
and Romanian family were pulled from the
Saint Lawrence River after the small
boat they were on sink in stormy weather
on Wednesday night
police recovered two bodies yesterday
after six people were pulled from a
marshy section of the riverbank on
Thursday it's believed the two families
including two children both Canadian
citizens were trying to cross into the
U.S illegally from Canada police have
located the overturned vessel as they
continue to search for the boat's owner
30-year-old Casey Oaks a resident of
aquasazne who's still missing
in the 2023 budget tabled on Tuesday the
Deputy Prime Minister and Finance
Minister Christopher Freeland promised
Canadians that Ottawa would find
billions of dollars in savings and cut
government waste the details she said
would come later our chief political
correspondent David Akins being digging
into that for us and David it seems one
place to start is the government's phone
bill
well far the federal government spends
millions of dollars every year for phone
lines thousands of which no one uses
questions on the order paper following
questions will be answered today it was
a written question a so-called order
paper question submitted by conservative
MP Adam Chambers you know people are
working differently how many phone lines
does the government pay for firstly and
are there ones we're paying for that
nobody's using we'd be tabled
immediately the answer he got the
government last year paid about 165
million dollars for more than 944
000 phone lines that's both cell phones
and landlines but by the government's
own admission more than 290
000 of those lines or 31 percent were
dormant they had not received or placed
a single call in three months or more
the government's I.T department is
called shared services Canada or SSC it
is responsible for the phone contracts
with most government departments the
minister in charge of SS C is Helena
jazic jazic was not available for an
interview but in a statement emailed to
Global News from SSC it said it had
already decommissioned about 50 000 of
those unused lines so far this year and
it's working with other government
departments to decommission most of the
rest inflation is significantly driving
Chambers who is a member of the commons
finance committee says cutting wasteful
spending is particularly important right
now former Bank of Canada Governor said
deficits last year are one of the
reasons why interest rates have been had
to go higher so if we want to have
interest rates come down we have to stop
the deficits and unnecessary wasteful
spending cutting back on the phone bill
is just one part of the Trudeau
government's promise in the budget to
review all government spending the
commitment made by Finance Minister
Chris jeffreyland a vow to find Savings
of 15 billion dollars over the next four
years pharah David again and Ottawa
thank you for that David and a new round
of federal taxes targeting carbon and
alcohol went into effect today driving
up the prices for patrons and at the
pump as well Canada's carbon pricing is
up from 50 to 65 dollars for a ton of
emissions that means Canadians can
expect to pay about three cents more per
liter of gasoline and from today a new
tax on alcohol will fuel a two percent
increase on all beer wine and spirits
but there is some relief the federal
minimum wage is up a dollar and 10 cents
to 16.65 cents an hour but that only
applies to federally regulated sectors
after the departure of Brenda lucky as
RCMP commissioner the mounties have a
new temporary boss interim commissioner
Mike duhen and he's taking the reins at
a pretty difficult time from a
blistering report over the rcmp's
performance over the worst mass shooting
in Canadian history to Growing concerns
it's overstretched and under-resourced
this week on the west block our Mercedes
Stevenson sits down with the interim
commissioner to discuss the future of
the RCMP including how it's handling
foreign interference
it's a tough time to wear the red surge
longest symbol of Canada around the
world the RCMP now frequently finds
itself under Fire but behind the scenes
the police must still carry out their
work including on foreign interference
and China's attempts to meddle in
Canada's democracy the RCMP when it
comes on the federal policing the not
our national security program has the
mandate to investigate any criminal
activity when it falls into the foreign
interference space and we are actively
engaged before Mike duhammer was
appointed interim leader of the RCMP he
was in charge of federal policing
handling files that included foreign
interference this week on the west walk
duhamem talks about the rcmp's role in
investigating and stopping foreign
interference saying the RCMP have
multiple investigations underway and
that he believes more charges are coming
we have several files that that we're
pursuing we've had success in some files
I think of the file that we had in the
province Quebec where there was an
individual working for hydro Quebec we
were successful in Lane charges against
this individual and we have other files
that are moving forward that we will be
successful in Lane charges ask
specifically about whether the RCMP
could or would charge those who we're
working at so-called Chinese police
stations in Canada to him made it clear
that the RCMP is looking at options when
it comes to the criminal code
well if you look at if there's any form
of intimidation or harassment on the
community itself that's a charge in
itself so again we have the the our
investigations are continuing in those
matters and if we gather enough evidence
to delay the appropriate charges we will
do so on the show the interim
commissioner also appeals to the
diaspora Community to come forward and
Report cases of interference or
intimidation to the RCMP particularly in
the cities of Vancouver Toronto and
Montreal where the mounties have
concerns we'll also talk about the
challenge of getting intelligence from
ceases Canada's spy agency in a way
where the RCMP are actually able to act
on it back to you
and you can watch more of Mercedes
interview with the interim commissioner
Sunday on the west block right here on
global
baby formula shortages dominated
headlines a year ago when the largest
manufacturing plant in the U.S shut down
after a recall was issued for several
powdered baby products that was linked
to the deaths of infants suffering a
bacterial infection the plants in
Michigan is still not working at 100
capacity and as Catherine Ward reports
Canadian parents are still struggling to
find the necessary products to feed
their little ones
you should be able to feed your child no
matter no matter what Julie Clark would
do anything for her eight-week-old
granddaughter Aubry sourcing formula has
been her Mission I tried like um smaller
communities larger communities big box
stores smaller chains and the formula
shelves were just Barren in February
2022 a formula plant in Michigan that's
applied most of Canada's formula
recalled a number of products following
reports of bacterial infections and was
forced to shut down for a period of time
reports indicate four babies were
infected and two of them died the
closure has had lasting impacts while
Canada doesn't produce any baby formula
for itself so we're fully reliant on the
Americans a year later the issue is
still a nightmare as formula Supply can
be limited I've had to switch three
times rights one mother we can't find
enough formula fast enough another says
each time we change I worry that he will
not be able able to take the formula
food industry researcher Sylvan
charlavois says problems continue at
Abbott nutrition in Michigan the Abbott
plant is actually still not fully
operational that's the thing they've had
some some issues with uh with without
breaks some food safety issues and in
general we actually learned that the
Department of Justice was actually
looking into the matter which is really
never good news tough times as families
do whatever it takes we were able to
allocate some of the powder
um in Florida and our friends drove it
home from Florida for US Health Canada
says it is aware of parents struggles
and is working with manufacturers but
there is little Clarity on when Supply
will improve chances are parents will
actually buy more and uh and it's hard
to blame them because there's so much
uncertainty Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
the neglected epidemic coming up how
covid-19 hindered HIV funds despite
increasing infections and advances in
treatment
[Music]
Pope Francis was in good spirits today
he's back in the Vatican after
undergoing antibiotic treatment for
bronchitis the 86 year old pontiff was
discharged from hospital in Rome this
morning the pope who was suffering
breathing difficulties is now preparing
to take part in a Palm Sunday service
tomorrow marking the beginning of a busy
Holy Week
during the pandemic the world attention
shifted to fighting off covet 19. yet
another epidemic has remained HIV AIDS
much progress has been made since the
first case was detected in Canada four
decades ago but there's still a long way
to go to eradicate the disease and
despite calls for Canada to do more to
prevent HIV and increase testing the
federal budget fell far short of what
Advocates were hoping for Sharia Israel
explains
when covid-19 emerged the push to
contain another virus took a back seat
it seems that people kind of almost
forgot about HIV vimbayi munyanara helps
women living with the disease in London
Ontario and her work is personal from a
very young age I've lost family members
friends but I also have a lot of family
friend family members and friends who
are living with HIV today she was born
in Zimbabwe a country with one of the
highest rates of HIV in the world
the first documented case in Canada was
41 years ago science has come a long way
since then groundbreaking discoveries
like antiretrovirals or Arts keep people
alive and prevent transmission by making
the virus undetectable there is no cure
but researchers at the University of
Ottawa are Paving a way towards one
pinpointing where the virus goes in the
body once it's become latent what we're
trying to do here is not replace the
antiretrovirals but to prevent the virus
from hiding so that we can actually get
rid of the virus we've made remarkable
progress in understanding the disease
but progress costs money the pandemic
drained resources for research and
slowed testing and treatment we're
clearly moving in the wrong direction We
Were Somehow being complacent in
thinking that this is no longer a crisis
and therefore we can just go on business
as usual last year the federal
government spent 50 million dollars on
HIV in and hepatitis C prevention
support and testing but Aid
organizations insist they need twice
that with infections increasing around
five percent annually it's shooting up
like from where it was and I can only
imagine it or I can only believe it's
due to the lack of funding and until
more action is taken Canadians living
with HIV will suffer unnecessarily
because Advocates believe it's not
science that's standing in the way of
progress but a lack of political will
Global News Ottawa
ahead can a company own a color one
artist's anti-commodification Crusade
[Music]
one of the best parts of spring is the
return of color into our lives and it's
something many of us take for granted
but in some ways it can be unexpectedly
challenging to access and that's why one
British Artist who's been dubbed the
Robin Hood of color is on a crusade to
make sure anyone can access every shade
of the spectrum Redmond Shannon reports
yeah so this is where we make all the
paints in the studio and Stuart simple
lives La Vie En Rose
I love watching it go in
not just pink yellow green the whole
rainbow
all developed here in his studio and
paint lab on the south coast of England
a renowned artist Semple has had his
work exhibited around the world success
he says is just a vehicle to drive his
non-profit art business so it's more
than how do I make money it's actually
more how do I make art accessible well
my accountant doesn't understand it so
they get really angry every year the joy
of RT argues shouldn't be a privilege of
the wealthy and I hate the idea that art
or color or materials are sort of gate
kept in any way shape or form
it's all part of his mission to liberate
colors from trademarked and protected
shades of paint to digital colors Out Of
Reach
sample recently built a free software
patch to help graphic designers and
artists to access online palettes that
suddenly disappeared behind a paywall
and it took me about two or three hours
and then I'd created this Freetown plug
sorry two or three hours yeah
yeah to get inside the software yeah and
fix this issue yeah and it's kind of
dirty I mean I could have done it better
if I'd have spent a bit longer but it
solved the problem it was the patch that
people needed so I made it
taking on the business of big color
leaves no room for yellow bellies
and have you consulted a lawyer yeah
yeah they always say the same thing
which that what I'm doing is risky a
risk he believes is worth taking one
shade at a time Redmond Shannon Global
News Bournemouth England
you can watch Redmond's full feature on
Stewart's sample on the new reality
tonight at seven right here on global
next Calgary in solidarity Today's
Special Day celebrating Greg and the
creative way people are protecting queer
and trans youth
[Music]
in the past few years drag shows have
exploded in popularity but it's come at
a price dangerous threats and
hate-fueled protests have made these
events a flash point in culture wars
across Canada and in the U.S today in
Calgary there was an outright show of
support and solidarity for the lgbtq2
plus Community dozens of drag shows
popped up at businesses around the city
and Beyond tonight Heather York's West
looks at Calgary's Campaign Of Love
within the queer Community the last few
months have been a tense time
week after week in cities across Canada
and the US drag and other lgbtq2 plus
events have been targeted by protesters
a game and a game it's really been
picking up steam since the summer since
um you're seeing more of these issues
being brought to lawmakers in the United
States
fueled by a false narrative that drag
time story hours and other family
friendly events are sexualizing children
and putting them at risk
lgbtq2 plus events have found themselves
continually under threat it's why a
group of queer community members in
Calgary have come together to stand up
to the hate it's been really inspiring
actually I as somebody who's been a long
time activist have been very impressed
people really just decided to come
together and do something about it why
can't boys wear skirts and bracelets
organizers say a month ago when it
became clear that attacks on the queer
Community were intensifying and not
going away the community came together
to form queer citizens united for the
qcu together they began brainstorming
ways to both protect community members
while showing them city-wide support
it's scary what we've heard from some of
the younger queer folks or younger drug
performers is it's scary to go into
these spaces that used to bring them a
lot of joy and so when drag events are
held now around the city you'll find
them surrounded by these hot pink fairy
Guardian protectors with wings 10 feet
tall so the way that this works is you
make these enormous barriers to cover up
the signs and close them in and all of
the all of the people who are
participating wear earplugs it's a
non-engagement principle originally
called Angels the wings were first used
to protect the family of Matthew Shepard
following his murder a homophobic hate
crime in 1998 two decades later the
Guardians have returned ensuring a new
gen generation of queer young people
feel protected and loved Heather urich's
West Global News Calgary
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
Saturday evening with us tonight's here
Canada is Canmore Alberta until tomorrow
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
foreign
[Music]